[Musique]
[Rires]
moi
je ne peux pas
delph des lettres des pierres des
lettres gravées sur les pierres
florilège de noms des personnes du passé
pas de fonction commémorative ici ses
nom prénom pseudo ou simple croix
désigne les esclaves affranchis des
gravures signe de liberté liberté des
corps enrôlés de force des milliers
d'humains libre de mouvement et de
pensée delph où l'on venait acheter sa
liberté et inscrire sur les pierres du
temple d'apollon sa signature pour que
jamais plus on est à se soumettre les
piasa texte donc mais aussi des
prophéties des paroles oraculaire qui
devaient orienter toute une vie de héros
de la mythologie de rois de simples
paysans
comprenez bien que d'elf
il ya des milliers d'années c'est le
centre d'humour
[Musique]
et
l'oncfs à loos le nombril du monde
évoqué par cette sculpture ombrie dalle
matérialise ce point le centre du monde
qui a reçu toutes les offrandes
possibles et imaginables
une simple chèvre sacrifier sur un hôtel
aux sculptures d'or d'argent et d'ivoire
delph lieu de tous les rassemblements et
de tous les trésors les trésor grec
sorte de petit temple érigé par chaque
région ou cité prospère certes à
remercier les dieux athènes sifnos naxos
et tant d'autres ont donné ce qu'elle
possédait de plus cher dans ces lieux
pausanias géographe et voyageur grec du
premier siècle de notre ère aurait pu
endosser le rôle de blogueurs antique
dans son texte perrier jez
il décrit tout ce qu'ils voient à mesure
qu'ils avancent le long de la voie
sacrée du sanctuaire de delphes tous les
trésors défile sous nos yeux
même ceux qui ont disparu avec le temps
en entrant dans la ville on trouve une
série de temple le premier était en
ruine est le suivant était vide de tout
statut divine ou humaine
quant au troisième et au quatrième l'un
contenait des statut d'empereur romain
en petit nombre et le dernier s'appelle
temple d'athéna prono ya
une description d'époque de ce lieu
mythique et mystique sur laquelle se
fonde aujourd'hui les spécialistes pour
réaliser des restitutions 3d des
édifices disparu du sanctuaire
si pausanias a volé à notre secours il
reste beaucoup d'énigmes à propos de ce
lieu et de son fonctionnement notamment
au sujet de la pythie la pythie et le
nom porté par l'oracle de delphes
l'interprète du dieu des générations
historiens se sont succédé sans qu'il
soit possible d'affirmer son identité
son origine dans ce cadre là il n'y a
que le mythe qui puisse nous éclairer
comme pour d'autres récits mythologiques
tout commence avec une créature
monstrueuse qui terrorisent les
habitants
adelphe ce n'est ni un minotaure nunes
singes mais un serpent dragon appelé
python qui vit dans une grotte à
l'emplacement du site actuel python est
attaqué par le dieu apollon est
gravement blessée d'une flèche il
s'enfuit dans le sein de sa mère la
terre par la brèche sacré ouvertes dans
des apollons le poursuit dans la brèche
sacré et de ce combat des vapeurs
mystique appelé pythonisse s'échappe
ces dernières inspire l'oracle qui de sa
bouche prononce les mots d'apollon sorte
de prophétie obscur appelé loxia ce
capable de prédire l'avenir
l'oracle de delphes prédit à eux dit
qu'il tuera son père et poussera sa mère
guiry de sa stérilité et j'espère de
taizé conseillera claisse durant ces
travaux et tant d'autres tant et si bien
qu'il est presque impossible d'échapper
à l'oracle dans la mythologie alors une
nouvelle fois et peut-être est-ce la
dernière
demandons nous ce que les archéologues
et spécialistes comprennent de ses
récits mythiques et en l'occurrence du
rôle politique intellectuel et spirituel
de la prêtresse de delphes d'une des
premières recherches des équipes
d'archéologues a justement été de
retrouver cette brèche sacré dans le sol
d'où s'échappe le nomma autrement appelé
le souffle l'inspiration on a compris
que le temple était bâtie par dessus la
brèche et que la pythie se plaçait sur
un trépied à la verticale pour un
exhaler les vapeurs l'oracle sans doute
une jeune fille vierge
l'habitante d'elf délivrer ces
prophéties une fois par mois avant la
consultation moment de transe elle
faisait ses ablutions buvait de l'eau de
la source kastali et machet du laurier
plus que les hypothétiques vapeur qui
s'échappe et du sol et dont il n'existe
aucun indice sur le site
ce sont sans doute les propriétés
toxiques du laurier quand il est ingéré
à haute dose qui peuvent expliquer la
transe de la pythie
elle répondait alors dans un état de
conscience altérée aux questions des
consultants de manière brève des membres
du sanctuaire l'accompagnait et avait la
charge de reformuler ses conseils sous
forme de verre des assistants veiller à
ce que le feu près d'elle ne s'éteigne
pas et sacrifier les offrandes des
pèlerins sur un hôtel dans le temple
tout cela était contrôlé par une sorte
de clergé ou confréries religieuses
pourquoi d'elf
pourquoi d'elfes et il le centre du
monde ce lieu primordial où se
bousculent tous les habitants réels ou
imaginaires de la grèce antique possède
aussi un mythe concernant sa
localisation
ce flanc de colline n'a pas été choisi
par hasard
revenons à notre bloc de calcaire
sculptée en forme de gilles l'umf à loos
selon la légende c'est sur ce point
précis que se seraient rencontrés deux
aigles envoyé par deux depuis les bords
opposés du monde
si l'on suppose que les aigles 10 20
volts à la même vitesse
c'est imparable c'est bien le centre du
monde
l'umf à l'eau serait ainsi la première
pierre du sanctuaire elle est décorée de
bandelettes de l'aisne qui symbolise le
centre religieux et philosophiques du
monde craque pour les archéologues cette
explication poétique n'est
malheureusement pas suffisantes
il faut comprendre les facilités
offertes par le terrain sa géologie son
accessibilité construits à flanc de
colline le site a été choisi pour son
emplacement sur un point haut mais aussi
et surtout pour la présence d'une source
la caste ali qui fait de ce lieu un site
favorable à l'établissement des
populations depuis l'âge du bronze
pour cette raison à partir du viiie
siècle avant notre ère on venait de tout
le continent pour consulter l'oracle des
personnes privées des représentants de
citer les souverains étrangers tels
crésus froide lydie et bien sûr les
héros de la mythologie d'elf tient aussi
un rôle de premier ordre dans la
colonisation grec de la méditerranée
puisque avant d'envoyer des colons
outre-mer on consulte l'oracle le nombre
de monuments de dons et d'inscriptions
que révèlent les fouilles archéologiques
à l'égard de la pythie témoigne de sa
notoriété
cela explique pourquoi la volonté de
certains de s'approprier ce lieu la cité
de crise a ou encore philippe de
macédoine et de dominer l'oracle a
généré plusieurs conflits d'elf est une
cité qui regorge de trésors et les désir
d'appropriation et de pillages sont
également nombreux on estime qu'une
bonne partie des donations ont été
pillés certaines pièces d'incroyables
comme lori joue encore les statuts crise
éléphantine faite d'or et d'ivoire mais
aussi le taureau d'argent ont été
conservés parce qu'elles avaient été
enterrés en 373 avant notre ère lors du
séisme qui provoqua l'écroulement du
temple finalement en 381 après
jésus-christ le sanctuaire est fermé par
l'empereur théodose
les fouilles archéologiques ont débuté
ici en 1840 il a fallu soixante quinze
ans pour exhumer une bonne partie des
monuments du site
les oeuvres sorties des fouilles sont
devenus immédiatement et universellement
célèbre l'homme fallows bien entendu
mais aussi l'origine la tôle os et le
trésor des athéniens mais ce qu'on
ignore bien souvent c'est que pour
découvrir les ruines de delta il a
d'abord fallu déplacer le village ancien
alors et alice le site antique des elfes
pour les grecs
c'est aussi une histoire d'expropriation
aujourd'hui delphi ville moderne n'a
plus rien à voir avec le village du
siècle dernier tout en bois et terre
crue recouverte de chaud tout ce
territoire est à présent circuit
touristique bien rodée aménagé de béton
et sa fonction à l'école et son mode de
vie traditionnel
relégué au rang des curiosités bientôt
elle aussi archéologiques
parce que d'elle fut élevé au rang de
centre du monde
on s'est permis d'exproprier toute une
population rurale celle qui vit de ses
productions agricoles et artisanales
[Musique]
faire revivre les mythes en oubliant
l'histoire d'un petit village cela peut
paraître injuste
cela n'a pas lieu systématiquement à
thèbes la ville moderne subsiste nous
privant sans doute de vestiges
magnifique à athènes aussi en partie
mais adult la tentation de savoir où se
situe le centre légendaire de la terre
primer sur tout et les populations sont
devenus négligeable aux yeux des
archéologues
oui c'est aussi ça l'archéologie donner
la priorité au passé de l'humanité sur
les besoins des vivants
[Musique]
l'archéologie implique toujours une part
de destruction ici quelques dizaines de
maisons construites par des mains de
charpentier déplacer pour restituer les
origines glorieuse de la civilisation
occidentale mais aussi pour comprendre
les origines des nues
[Musique]